depuis inventif événements
étaient liés aux cdo et amoureux de
marianne mais malheureusement marianne
est déjà marié c'est une histoire
d'amour qui se jouait à la salle de
spectacles jean vilar à marly-le-roi et
caprices de marianne pièce écrite par
alfred de musset et mise en scène par
rock antoine albaladejo on passe d'un
lieu à un autre en une seconde d'une
d'une ruelle à l'intérieur d'une chambre
un petit salon et donc du coup cette
particularité donne un côté très
dynamique et presque cinématographique à
la pièce et moi c'est ça aussi qui m'a
beaucoup plu parce que du coup on avait
imaginé tout un travail sur les liaisons
pour passer d'une scène à l'autre et
pour cela un orchestre et mise en place
puisque la pièce revisitant version
cabaret chicago
[Musique]
à c
là
et puis l'originalité c'est le la mise
en musique ou en fait on a vraiment un
répertoire on a créé un répertoire d'une
dizaine de chansons que nous avons écrit
nous mêmes
musicalement on s'est inspiré aussi
d'autres chansons des standards de jazz
ou autres personnages emblématiques de
la pièce octave amis de ces lieux il va
tout faire pour intercéder en sa faveur
auprès de marianne c'est un peu un des
musiciens du groupe k a été constitué et
qu'un petit peu l'animation et le choeur
bâton de débats font de ce spectacle un
personnage d'octave est un personnage
qui a une trajectoire absolument
incroyable dramaturgiquement c'est un
personnage qui est
l'allégorie presque de l'insouciance et
de l'ivresse sur scène ils sont neuf
comédiens mais ils ont aussi la
particularité d'être musicien une
interprétation pluriel pour parfaire
cette histoire d'amour